有一句话，
其实好多姐妹都听那句话，
都听明白是啥意思了，
就是你一定要充分的去享受一种状态，
这种状态叫什么？
叫仁至义尽之后心安理得的无情无义，
这种状态巨少，
我今年在过年是22岁，
小姐姐她是单亲妈妈，
现在是失业，
有负债，
但是付了多少我不知道，
孩子是男孩三岁，
今年9月份上学，
我是从孩子六七月份的时候开始全职带娃，
然后今年9月份我就开始搬出来独立了，
但是他现在呢，
又要求我回去再给他继续带，
我就很犹豫，
其实我是不想回去的，
不想回去我理解你，
因为德华不是这么好当的，
一般你在网上看那些愿意当德华的是要给钱的，
但是一开始会每个月给我3000块钱，
但是我后面又自己接触了假发事业嘛，
我假发能自己接班了之后，
就我自己挣假发的，
就是我是很心疼他，
我去帮他带娃，
但是我自己也很痛苦，
家里还有老人吗？
我爸妈都帮不了忙，
孩子爸把你家可以当做苦不？
我觉得这个事情哦，
一定要尊重自己的内心，
不要被任何人道德绑架，
就你明确的说，
我带娃我真的很痛苦，
我带娃我真的很没有耐心，
我还不如说。
如果我挣钱多的话，
我可以，
经济上我现在因为你困难嘛，
是吧，
咱俩亲姐妹，
经济上我稍微贴点给你都可以，
你自己找一个早上晚上来的，
10月份搬出来，
当时也是因为孩子吵架的，
但是他说我对孩子态度不好，
但其实我只是忙，
我每天就是带娃，
然后我也没有社交，
我的朋友还是之前上班的时候交的朋友，
就每天都跑到房间里，
然后我做完假发出来之后，
我就想想了，
告松你，
我们小孩老缠着我，
我就有点烦了，
他就说我带一孩子后就去好，
然们就吵架，
然后我就说那我不带了，
我不想带了，
我就天走啊。
然后我就看房子，
在书房子签合同，
这三个指点我都跟他说了，
他就说那你去呗，
我是在确认他，
如果他不让我走的话，
那我就不走了，
但是他说你去呗，
那我就签合同，
那我就担心他住了，
那做的对，
没有问题，
姑娘没有问题，
你姐姐的这种做法其实是自私的，
因为你是一个20出头的姑娘，
我说句难听点的话，
这孩子不是你生的，
可能带着带着的话，
你最后你都不想要孩子，
都有可能，
我们现在是有点恐怖口虑就是嘛，
所以你姐姐这个做法是自私的，
你搬出来没有亏欠任何人，
如果你觉得心疼你姐姐不容易，
还是那句话，
你多挣钱呀，
这个阶段你借你姐姐点钱呀，
帮衬帮衬他，
这个可以呀，
折腾搬出来。
哦，
我给了他1万块钱，
前两天昨有舞蹈课，
在他那个小区附近嘛，
我可能在都会去两次，
我每次去我都会带东西，
就没有空手去过，
然后这两天又带孩子，
他们一起去吃的火锅，
然后之后我们的关系就缓和了，
就不要待在一个房间里的时候，
就很冷冰冰的，
我就有一种寄人篱下的那种感觉，
然后跟我商量个事儿，
说他今天房租太贵了，
想搬到我附近的小区，
我想我晚上去帮他带一下，
然后就怎么念了，
当时是犹犹豫豫，
但是我不能想了一下，
我不能再回到那种状态了，
我真的很崩溃，
我感觉我带不了孩子，
那就要尊重自己的内心，
我给你举一个例子吧，
姑娘啊，
这个例子可能未必很恰当，
但是我就想分享给你，
人一定要尊重自己的内心，
哪怕我这么干会让人骂我都行，
更何况你这么干还没有人骂你。
我自己的亲生的例子啊，
就说如果有一天有个姐妹就问我说我婆婆要是生病了，
我会不会去照顾我婆婆啊，
会不会去陪床啊什么的，
我就说就算我亲爹亲妈生病了，
我都不会去陪床，
我也不会去照顾她，
我也不会去端屎端尿，
我也不会给他擦挤身体，
我可以出钱。
然后很多人都骂我，
大概就是说我们没有孝心，
或者怎么怎么样，
我承认，
但是我就是真实的面对我自己，
而且我跟我父母之间的这种关系的话，
我父母也非常艰难。
我父母也非常坦然的接纳，
说啊，
给钱就很好了，
他们也知道，
他们也接纳，
就这意思，
就说你一定要诚实的面对你的内心，
哪怕你做这个决定会让有人觉得骂你，
那你也要诚实的面对你的内心，
更何况你做这个决定，
我认为啊，
是符合现在年轻人的百分之八九十以上的标准的，
没有人骂你，
但是我就是很心疼他，
我可能是一个比较感性的人，
我的情感早就会控制我的理智，
我就很心疼他，
自己一个人抱孩子不容易，
然后他现在也失业，
他还有房租，
是孩子又是个痛经受，
我不想帮他，
但是我不想去干，
真的我在带孩子，
社会崩溃我对呀，
那就明说呀，
姐，
我现在如果说我手头有富裕的钱的话，
我可以匀一匀，
我可以帮衬帮衬你，
你找个钟点工，
几点来几点走，
能帮你带孩子，
你自己是吧，
装监控，
我也可以帮你看着监控，
这可以，
但是我带孩子我真脾气也不好，
我现在也有点抑郁，
我带孩子我怕我对孩子发脾气，
也伤感情，
伤了咱俩的感情啊，
伤孩子的感情。
他那天晚上来找我商量之后回去，
过了几天我又给他打了个视频，
因为我平时就很少发消息，
都是打视频了，
说我考虑了一下，
我带不了他就有点不高兴，
他就是说意思就是我才20岁，
就好像我还年轻，
我的时间可以就是。
帮他带孩子或者怎么样，
那是他自负，
他不讲道理，
不要陷入他的那种逻辑里面去，
就说这个孩子我都带那么长时间了，
我真的是带前在我早就不想带孩子了，
然后孩子的听大的话，
现在是那个进去了，
今年七月份才会出来，
冬天的话也是没有回了了，
所以什么我就想着我怎么能帮到他，
你要帮到他的话，
那你只能是你多挣钱了，
你一个月匀个一千两千来给他先急用，
因为我十月份才出来嘛，
我首先是自由职业了，
我就在家里边，
我就可以做，
然后我平均一个月是可以收入1万多，
或者是八九千这样子的，
那就很好了。
姑娘啊，
最多是什么，
就是你姐家里装个监控，
你说你分享一个监控给我，
我平时在家工作的时候，
我可以通过监控看着阿姨，
只要阿姨没有打孩子，
没有骂孩子，
没有对孩子不好的话，
挺好，
你最多能做到这儿，
我就说你可以找托管啊，
或者说找保姆，
他说找保姆我一个月挣5000，
就得给他3000，
找托管她也不放心，
还是那句话，
姑娘，
你姐很自私，
你要清醒一点啊，
温柔且坚定，
就是能处处不能处，
反正你现在人大了20多岁了，
你能养活自己了，
你怕啥呢？
我现在都是这种心态，
我跟你讲啊，
所有的姐妹们啊，
现在对亲人都是这种心态，
能处处不能处，
我现在反正也。
不满意吗？
谁怕谁呀，
就是这种心态，
我就想着，
因为他小，
我小的时候他对我很好，
家里边儿买房子他也出钱，
家具都是他买的，
然后他现在过成这样子，
我就有点不冷自因此我就不想放弃我自己，
我就非常的焦虑，
天晚上我就睡不着觉，
我感觉我说的可清楚了呀，
就给钱呀，
他小时候对你好，
你现在给钱呀，
是不是我一个月我给你贴3000还不够吗？
行对不对？
我以后不怎么跟他去相处，
就还像平常一样吗？
能处处不能处，
反正你是网瘾吗？
他要是能回过味来咱就处，
他要是回不过味儿来，
他觉得你亏欠他了，
那咱就不处，
有什么大不了的呢？
嗯，
那我现在就是你们在多赚钱，
我特别喜欢看你的直播，
我看你直播两三年了，
你的书我也买过啊，
好，
谢谢你啊，
姑娘有一句话，
其实好多姐妹都听这句话，
都听明白是啥意思了，
就是你一定要充分的去享受一种状态，
这种状态叫什么？
叫仁至义尽之后心安理得的无情无义，
这种状态聚爽好的，
谢谢老女士，
好拜拜啊，
不知道我这句话能戳中多少人，
我戳中的全是那个一直吃亏的，
一直奉献的，
一直贴补的，
戳中的全是这帮善良的人，
你一定要充分去享受这个状态，
就是仁至义尽。
之后心安理得的无情无义的状态啊，
巨爽，
超级爽，
特别爽，
真的跟着龙飞姐的话就少了很多内耗，
少了很多对自己的攻击，
记得点赞关注哦。